unos 25 millones de personas son
Víctimas de trata cada año en todo el
mundo así lo señala el nuevo informe del
departamento de estado de Estados Unidos
una situación que desestabiliza las
sociedades atenta contra los derechos
humanos y socava las economías de los
países
la escala de este problema es enorme hay
cerca de 25 millones de personas
Víctimas de trata
21 países ascendieron de nivel a Porque
esos gobiernos hicieron esfuerzos para
combatir el tráfico así como para sus
ciudadanos en el extranjero 18 países
fueron degradados lo que indica que no
hicieron mayores esfuerzos para combatir
el tráfico o peor aún que sus gobiernos
tienen una política o un patrón de
tráfico patrocinado por el estado
este año debido a la guerra en Ucrania
Washington puso a Rusia en la lista de
países involucrados en una política de
trata de personas trabajo forzado y
reclutamiento de niños soldado junto a
otras 16 naciones como Nicaragua
medicina o Venezuela componen la lista
negra de Naciones que no hacen lo
suficiente otra categoría establece un
nivel de vigilancia a más de 40
gobiernos que no cumplen plenamente con
las normas mínimas como belarús debido a
la crisis migratoria en sus fronteras en
2021 también están Haití y Camboya
además el informe revela que la crisis
por el covid 19 y el cierre de las
fronteras tuvo un efecto
desproporcionado sobre las víctimas
incrementando sus vulnerabilidades así
como el abandono escolar de menores el
trabajo forzado o la esclavitud sexual a
la que se ven sometidos por las
desigualdades endémicas de estos países